[Music]
foreign
of course I want to get to the top I
think any anyone in my position will be
saying they want to get to the top of
Motorsport and being Formula One I don't
think there's any reason whatsoever why
there shouldn't be a female driver on
the F1 Grid it's not the work of a
minute it's not the flick of a switch
some drivers are fortunate enough to
either be paid to race or have enough
sponsorship that they're able to earn a
living out of it
[Music]
formula one has seen Global interest
explode in recent years and with that
new audience there's come a realization
from within the sport that it needs to
be more diverse and that includes on
track so that's why F1 decided to launch
its own all-female racing Championship
F1 Academy is a series started by
Formula One to really Aid the
progression of female drivers in our
sport it's with the best five junior
teams and the aim is to really help
those 15 Young Drivers to be nurtured to
be the best racing drivers there they
can be to then obviously go on to
further progression in the sport
essentially F1 Academy is a kind of
talent incubator that takes top female
drivers and gives them the time on track
so that they can compete against their
male counterparts
foreign
Carlin is quite a well-established team
it's one of the top junior teams in the
world we kind of pride ourselves on on
kind of forming the ladder basically
we're taking drivers from karting to the
Dora Formula One a few notable names
that are passed through our doors would
be Sebastian Vettel Daniel Ricardo
Carlos science Jr more recently Landon
Norris and Logan sergeant and those guys
went straight from Carlin to formula one
so it's been really nice to be part of
that story and to see kind of the
success that those guys are now having
and what would be really great would be
to send a female driver after them
that's that's also been through the team
[Music]
I'm Abby pulling I'm an Alpine Academy
driver racing Road and Carlin this year
in the F1 Academy I got into racing
through my dad actually he raced long
circuit motorbikes endurance so a little
bit different to what I'm doing I'm on
four wheelers instead of two
um yeah I've been in in a race Paddock
since I could remember a bit before
eight I kind of started pestering my dad
you know when can I have a go when can I
ever go and
yeah age of eight I got my own go-kart
and and then that's kind of where
everything started as soon as I jumped
in the car and I came back home I was
like okay when we going again it was it
was something I've always wanted to do
every day of my life
um it was only kind of when I got to the
age of maybe 14 15 16 where I was like
actually I want to go the next step and
go into cars and try and make a
professional career out of it one thing
I always say that I love about racing is
how it like brings people together and
I'm very close to my dad because of the
racing obviously you know there's things
like the speed and challenging yourself
and getting better and seeing that lap
time come down is just such a very
satisfying feeling but yeah I think how
the people you meet and the lessons you
learn I think is what I love as well
[Music]
all right
what marks Motor Racing out from other
sports is that just to compete you need
a huge amount of money behind you
carting costs can run into the tens of
thousands of pounds and those numbers
just rise quickly once you get into F4
or F3 F2 so if you're really talented
you're still going to need hundreds of
thousands of pounds a year just to get
on track and that's before you get close
to Formula One there are many challenges
for for women wanting to be drivers in
Motorsport and to be honest a lot of
those are shared with male drivers as
well when we show people around our
Factory or we welcome people to the
racetrack and show them around and they
don't have much knowledge of Motorsport
they're always quite surprised at the
business model it's you know they'll ask
us how much the drivers get paid to
compete and actually it's completely the
opposite even in Formula One there's
drivers that have to bring a sponsorship
budget to their team in order to compete
you know the teams provide the cars the
engineers the mechanics the truck you
know everything else to form that
package but the driver has to bring that
budget
my name is Megan dilks and I'm a driver
for Road and Carlin in the F1 Academy
and a Trackside support engineer and
Aston Martin Formula One very few
drivers are able to make a really really
healthy living out of motive for some
drivers are fortunate enough to either
be paid to race or have enough
sponsorship that they're able to earn a
living out of it but quite often drivers
are just scraping by trying to find the
budget to be able to go racing I've
definitely spent probably more time
finding money than actually driving the
car I've been doing it since I was in
secondary school and going through my
gcses I was you know I was in business
and my business teacher would come and
be like what are you doing on the
computer and I'm like I think and I'll
be on you know PowerPoint making a
sponge proposal networking is a huge
thing takes up you know tons of time if
if I'm not racing on a race weekend of
my own I'll normally be at different
race weekend networking and somewhere in
the UK so so it's yeah it's a full-time
job away from
the racing as a full-time job my goal
has always been to make it to F1 and as
a little kid I always wanted to be a
racing driver having you know started
off in currents that was my dream I want
to be an F1 driver I'm a race
professionally and um
reality sort of hits and you realize the
amount of talent budget and luck that
you need to to make it to F1 when
there's 20 seats on the F1 grid and many
many thousands of drivers that are vying
for those seats
um I decided that I needed a bit of a
backup plan and that was engineering so
at the moment my goal is to someday
become a a race engineer in F1
[Music]
physiologically you know a 19 year old
woman is not going to start off as
strong as a 19 year old man that's just
the way it is so we have to kind of
overcompensate for that through training
some people don't even count motorizing
as a sport but it absolutely is you know
the driver is out there it's a very high
pressure environment they are
experiencing g-forces they have to be
strong they have to be light so we're
looking for lean muscle but it has you
know they have to have a core strength
they have to have strong arms the force
alone that they're putting through the
brake pedal is is beyond what anybody
would you know normally comprehend it's
you know essentially stamping into the
ground as hard as you can so there are a
lot of physical demands when I'm at home
I go to the gym every day and go on a
bike for like a three-hour bike ride
once a week
um well obviously when I'm aware of
wrestling there's only like two days in
a week physically it's like your neck
and your shoulders and maybe a little
bit your brick leg I was kind of used to
like the neck and the arms from Carton
and what the leg my legs definitely I
had to strengthen up a lot to come into
chorus and the broke is like really hard
to press and a car compared to a carton
the thing about the F1 car is is your
neck you've got to be so strong in your
neck for the g-forces so although I've
not experienced it before I think you
know as long as you you put your mind to
it and like I say train every day you
know I think a female can get to that
level we get to our Peak physicality you
know maybe late 20s opposed to early 20s
like a male so you know it might be that
it just takes a little bit longer and it
takes someone a bit older and it's you
know it's got a I think you've got a
weight up a bit as an F1 team does the
age actually really matter
it's not unheard of for women to compete
in Formula One over the years a handful
of female drivers have made it onto the
Grid in the 1950s Maria Theresa de
Filippis became the first woman to join
an F1 race then in the 70s Leila
Lombardi competed in a dozen races and
even won points
more recently Giovanna amati took part
in qualifying for the Brazilian Grand
Prix that was one for 30 years ago and
since then the closest any woman has got
is as a test or development driver for
an F1 team Motorsport isn't segregated
women race against men it's one of the
three sports in the world which isn't
segregated alongside sailing obviously
involved quite a big board at horse
riding or jumping involves a big animal
and water sport which involves a big car
and I think Formula One generally
Motorsports fundamentally always been
seen as very male dominated it is to a
certain extent still very mild dominated
but the sport is changing I think this
huge growing fan base the the fastest
growing demographic in that new fan base
is a young female audience so we want to
make sure that we're capitalizing on
that and showing that our sport has
opportunity for women there have been
previous attempts to run all-female
racing competitions but they've always
had to stand on their own two feet the
high costs associated with Motorsport
mean that it's very difficult to make
the finances stack up but by having the
support of formula one's operational
broadcasts and Commercial Machinery F1
Academy has a huge advantage over all
those past efforts
finances have always been an issue and
will always be an issue that is the
nature of our sport it's not like
football or tennis which in the end if
you have a pitch in a ball or a court
and a ball you can go and practice
the nature of this sport means you need
a team when you need a car and that
obviously has implications financially
Nikki louder had to finance his his way
into Formula One initially so I think
we're not going to be able to change
that but obviously with F1 Academy we
are giving the driver huge financial aid
to make sure that the drivers are
getting enough track time and are
getting all the possibilities to try and
progress in the sport the more you
practice at something the better you're
going to be Talent will only get you so
far and in Motorsport that translates to
time on track so the more time on track
you have the more time there is to hone
that Talent hone that racecraft become
more confident so everything becomes
second nature at the moment I think it's
a great time to be a female sport
there's the most support they've ever
had you know there's so many programs
initiatives being put in place and
championships like F1 Academy which is
all female but provides great track time
and you know development for us females
to to push us forward to go into mixed
competition you of making it to Formula
One and you do a lot of preparation a
lot of work to get there but I will
never forget the the first moment I hit
the track at Silverstone in the Williams
Formula One car
I was so well prepared I knew exactly
what was expected of me I knew exactly
what I had to achieve in the car but I
still had that moment of how this is
incredible and what that car is capable
of in terms of its breaking performance
its cornering speed because of the huge
aerodynamic effect
it is I can only say it's incredible
foreign
this is the launch event for our
partnership with F1 Academy and
Motorsport UK which is all about kind of
broadening the talent base of girls
competing in Motorsport we have about
1.8 million drivers a year about a third
of them are female but when it comes to
them progressing up to racing
competitively in our Academy programs
they only have about five percent female
in them at the moment and we really want
to address that balance and encourage
more girls to take up karting at the
Grassroots level I think that's one of
the magical things about a go-kart it's
not only a miniature machine but it's a
it's a microcosm of all the skills that
you need to drive pretty much every type
of competition car I think famously Ed
and Senna when he was asked what his
favorite
form of Motorsport was he said well I
have two Formula One of course but also
karting because it's the purest form of
Motorsport and the skills that you need
in order to drive that quickly around an
indoor cart circuit it's exactly the
same as you need to drive a Formula One
car maybe just a bit quicker the skills
that you do take through is things like
braking your racing lines and throttle
application there the three kind of big
things and then also the racecraft the
racecraft is like nothing else in racing
in a go-kart and 1000 karting is key to
getting more you know getting a female
to Formula One I think you know at the
end of the day if it's not just girls in
the F1 Academy that get there it's the
10 year olds watching or eight-year-olds
watching uh they're inspired to jump
into a go-kart to then progress through
the ladder and you know in 20 years time
then there will be you know at that age
where they're looking to go and make
that step into Formula One and it's so
important to inspire the young
generations and get them in early and
and open up that Avenue and opportunity
to them early on when it comes to
finding a female driver who can get to
the very top of Motorsport ultimately
it's a numbers game that means getting
more girls into racing from an early age
and then keeping them on track as much
as possible I think recently we've seen
a slight increase in participation of
women in Motorsport and that's because
Society has changed there's more of a
belief that probably there are
opportunities there but what I do think
has been missing is just the
accessibility to the sport and that's
where I really think
F1 Academy can play a big role we can
break down the accessibility we can
Inspire we can create Global awareness
for all of those young girls that are
currently racing and karting we want to
be the bridge into single seaters we
want to nurture and develop the talent
and that's something which I think
has been missing in the past
ultimately to be successful in
Motorsport you need to have a very
competitive nature
you need to be very determined
you need to like the adrenaline and the
pressure that comes with competing a
racing driver has to be able to
withstand a lot of pressure they're out
there with the focus on them but behind
them is a team of people that have put
weekends aside evenings aside work
through the night to get their car ready
a team of people looking at them people
on the internet people on TV watching
them so they already have to withstand a
lot of pressure
when you add to that that a female
driver is going to attract far more
attention potentially far more criticism
then that requires again another level
of determination and that's what I think
our drivers have and I I see it in them
I've never I've never really experienced
anything where someone's
made me feel like I can't do something
because because I'm a female you know
it's it's all moving in in the right
direction and the only time that I've
ever really experienced anything is
um it'll be the dads in go-karting when
you know when I was eight years old and
I'd be there there lad that's all you
know eight nine years old and they'll be
like you can't have a girl beat you for
every high that you have in molar sport
there's probably about 10 or 15 low
moments as well you've got to be when
you get to the Circuit even before you
get to the Circuit you've got to be
ready to expect anything that could
happen the truth is sport is brutal you
lose more than you win because there's
only ever One winner
and for me without a doubt the most
important character tree I had was
tenacity I just chose not to give up
are we going to see a female driver in
Formula One in the future absolutely yes
if we don't then I have failed and I
truly believe it's going to take time
but there is Talent out there and
nurtured in the right way we will see a
woman in Formula One we're not going to
produce
an F1 Champion potentially in season one
because this is about creating Role
Models it's about investing in these
drivers and giving them opportunity and
you can't overnight kind of just turn
that into an F1 driver I think in five
ten years time we are going to see that
happen there's no reason why it
shouldn't it absolutely has to because
we're missing out on a whole pool of
talent that's just so far been neglected
um but it is going to take a little
while but my Ultimate Dream will be F1
but I think realistically I would just
like to get as far as I can in a career
and more spot I'm not in in a bad
position you know the F1 Academy is
providing a great platform for for the
drivers to to develop with the seat time
that they're providing and then also the
progression path that they're also
offering is is great so you know
hopefully if I get a few more
um good good results in hopefully it
will help again me progress further I'm
happy to be where I am I'm happy to be
driving you know it's
any year that you're driving it's a good
year so it could be worse